murray how's it going good to see you
i'm good great to meet you carlos
uh vinnie is amazing like
fantastic when can i take classes with
either you or
then i'll accept either one
well i'm actually you're funny you
should mention that i've actually i'm
actually starting my own studio and you
can sign up um i can send you a link and
uh we can get started yeah do we all
have to wear the shorts is that a
prerequisite for coming absolutely
absolutely
that's not a problem right no no no no
we're good i think we're good you know
do some squats first so to to what can
do you attribute
your um ability to do all those amazing
moves
great choreographers
who tailored
tailored things to what i was capable of
um funnily enough like i kind of took to
it like dr water in some ways in that
like i was like oh my god this is so fun
but yeah they uh the choreographers on
the show are brilliant and they really
created something that was you know
mostly within my reach and uh that was
super fun and like you know correct for
the the period so uh yeah
uh
vinnie is full of energy and he
seemingly has kind of kind of has it all
though you know we know that there is
that twist in there and there's darkness
in there which you play really well when
i add right off the top is that
something that really attracted you to
the idea of playing this character that
there are those sides
yeah i mean it's one of the things that
attracts me to this show because i feel
like all the characters are
beautifully complex in that way and that
you know you you get to see their inner
life and as well as their sort of you
know what they present to the world and
um
you know sheila particularly
that you you know you
you see who she's presenting to the
world but you get to hear what's going
on inside and it's frightening and
confronting and very relatable i think
and you know and similarly we get to see
that with uh with vinnie green not in
terms of his
inner voice but the the kind of
because they're these sort of
um
kindred spirits really sort of
recognizing a similar sort of
uh
similar type in terms of having a very
kind of dynamic you know public face
and a very you know a lot of kind of
demons that they're kind of sitting on
and a sort of a complex inner world that
they hide from
from the outside world um so yeah i i
mean
that's a fantastic thing to be able to
dive into as an actor and a really great
thing to play that you know that's this
complex character with these
um you know
these sort of conflicting things um to
play which is you know what makes us
human you know it it makes it a very you
know rich three-dimensional character
there's a sequence in an episode between
you and rose that i absolutely adore and
i'm not going to give away what it is
but i think you know what i'm talking
about yeah i think i do what was it like
putting all that together with her
i mean
you know it
it's really fun working on this show you
know
um and
yeah we you know again like we had these
great choreographers on this show
and just imaginative writers just the
fact that you know without giving
anything away
it's a it's a very
um
unusual scene um
and the fact that you know
the the the writers create
such sort of specific like
wonderfully imaginative scenes like that
it's so kind of
thrilling just to read on the page and
be like oh my god you know um this is
it's something different and
it's also you know it's as will become
apparent when you know people see that
scene it's like it's connected to what
drives these two characters they
they're in this world of movement and
stuff and and um
so it's it's very clever in that it's
not just sort of like a
a fun sort of novel scene it's actually
connected to
what drives these characters you know um
but it was you know that was a long day
and it's like doing a scene like that
that is unusual and it's not just like
two people sitting at a table talking is
um
is
super fun and also like
complicated but it's like this beautiful
puzzle that you get to kind of put
together
and you know working with rose is just
absolutely
dreamy so we had a lot of fun together
um
you know they called cut and we're like
hey rose how are you going because we're
both australia you're both australian so
it's kind of hilarious but uh yeah it's
uh no it was a joy that's awesome well
you guys are so great in it uh
congratulations on the show uh thanks
for taking the time thank you
you